[Musik]
willkommen zur zdf heute live mit ihrem
live stream zu aktuellen fragen und
ereignissen und da stellen wir heute
fest die zahl der korona patienten auf
den intensivstationen steigt wieder
deutlich an da gibt es zwar noch freie
betten
aber der höhepunkt kommt noch so scheint
es zumindest
rki-präsident herr wieler hat sich heute
in seiner pressekonferenz besorgt über
die situation in den krankenhäusern
geäußert es kommt zunehmend zu akuten
einschränkung des betriebs aufgrund von
personalmangel und tatsächlich hat sich
die anzahl der klinik mit dieser meldung
in den letzten vier wochen verdoppelt
rückmeldung aus der intensiv medizin
bestätigen dass jetzt schon der
regelbetrieb in einigen kliniken
eingeschränkt werden muss um personal
für die intensivstation freizusetzen
und wenn wir da mal auf die zahlen
gucken der intensivpatienten die mit 19
behandelt werden dann zeigt sich dieser
trend sehr deutlich wir haben das neue
vorbereitet hier und zwar kann man sehen
im april geht die kurve deutlich nach
oben dann flacht sie ab und am 11.11
haben wir einen neuen höchststand von
3127 kur wird 19 intensivpatienten dass
es höher als der höchste stand im april
da waren es 2008 150
rein zahlenmäßig gibt es aber noch genug
intensivbetten das sagt zumindest dass
die wie intensiv register aber das
pflegepersonal reicht nicht und darüber
möchte heute heute reden sie sehen sie
schon hinter mir franziska bühler
ehemalige intensiv krankenschwester hat
ein buch darüber geschrieben und später
werden wir noch zum chef der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft schalten den
präsidenten doktorgrad gast aber jetzt
erst mal hallo franziska müller hallo du
hast ein buch geschrieben dass dieses
jahr viel aufmerksamkeit gefunden hat
weil es in eine zeit viel wo es auf
einmal sehr um die pflege ging was ist
denn so der tenor seines buchs also wir
haben mit dem buch alle bereiche der
pflege beleuchtet wir haben
herausgearbeitet wo liegen die probleme
was das sind die probleme
woran krankt unser system aber werden
auch die guten seiten nicht vergessen
woran krankt in unser system wir haben
gerade schon gehört es fehlt vor allem
an personal ist das tatsächlich die
größte herausforderung derzeit
und der hauptproblem ist der
personalmangel ja auch der
intensivstation fehlern geschätzt 5 5000
kollegen und ich glaube deutschlandweit
sind das was 30.000 in allen bereichen
wie zeigt sich das dann in der täglichen
arbeit oder wie hat sich das gezeigt du
bist ja dann doch wieder ausgeschieden
nach sehr langer zeit endlich das
umgesetzt auf eine andere station aber
wie hat sich das den täglichen arbeiten
gezeigt dass menschen gefehlt haben
also das ist nicht von heute auf morgen
passiert das war eher so ein
schleichender prozess ja ich kann mich
erinnern als ich 2007 auf der
intensivstation angefangen habe da gab
es mal krankheitsausfälle und dann hat
man mal telefoniert im dienstplan
geguckt wer kann einspringen
dann sind aber über die jahre einfach
weniger leute nachgekommen kollegen sind
in rente gegangen
dann sind ganz viele kollegen
ausgeschieden haben sich ins studium
geflüchtet oder sich versetzen lassen
und letztlich sind wir dann einen punkt
gekommen an dem wir das auch aus eigenen
reihen mit einspringen nicht mehr
kompensieren konnten und eigentlich
wirklich dann zum schluss in dauerhaft
der unterbesetzung mitgearbeitet
das heißt der notzustand ist der
normalzustand geworden
sowohl kann man das sagen so fühlt es
sich auch an mir hat er die kranken aus
haltern überhaupt nicht versucht gegen
zu arbeiten hat man das dann einfach so
laufen lassen
na gut man kann sich kein pflegepersonal
backen ja dass das geht natürlich nicht
und in letzter konsequenz ist muss man
den betten schreiben das haben wir dann
auch regelhaft gemacht du warst jetzt
aber anfang des jahres quasi schon mit
einem bein raus aus der intensivstation
bis dann wieder zurückgegangen was war
die motivation also ich wollte helfen
ich arbeite ja nun in den bereichen die
wir elektro operieren und das
elektrogeschäft route nun im frühjahr
also hast du glaub ich ein werden
effektiv geschäft ja das heißt dass alle
geplanten operationen also der fallen
zum beispiel auch mit prothesen
knieprothesen
derlei sachen darunter das hat man
ausgesetzt das war nicht statt und bevor
irgendein zuhause saß er in den schoß
gelegt habe dachte ich mir ich gehe
zurück packt mit an bin dann eben noch
mal mit einer halben stelle zurück auf
die korrekt intensiv und haben vier
wochen gearbeitet was waren das für vier
wochen wie hast du die erlebt also ich
hab die stationen betreten die ich nicht
mehr wiedererkannt habe wohl nicht zwei
wochen erst weg waren die station bei
umstrukturiert wir haben eine eigene
infektionsstation mit eigenen
zugangswegen versorgungswege und wir
haben das personal maximal aufgestockt
also der arbeitet kinderärzte mit uns
ots aus dem op also ganz viele
verschiedene fachrichtungen ganz viele
freiwillige die sich auch hunde den
peripheren stationen gemeldet haben um
zu helfen und so konnten wir dann quasi
die das patientenaufkommen das doch
relativ hoch war so um ostern herum gut
managen gut ständen
was ist das für ein allzeit wie stelle
ich mir das vor wenn ich auf so einer
intensivstation also auch gerade auf
marco witt intensivstation arbeite wie
unterscheidet die sich jetzt auch von
der arbeit auf einer ich sag mal
normalen intensivstation
die verbindung ist schlecht ich habe die
frage könnte die frage nicht mehr die
frage war wie unterscheidet sich die
arbeit auch so ein akku wird
intensivstation von der arbeit auf einer
normalen intensivstation wie muss ich
mir das vorstellen im täglichen geschäft
achso und der mut also der unterschied
ist einfach dass das alles isolations
zimmer sind ja also vor jedem zimmer
steht ein großer wagen mit
schutzkleidung mit face schädels mit mit
hauben mit mit extra handschuhen mit fp3
masken und da muss man sich eben
vermummen ja also schutzkleidung
anziehen ins zimmer rein gehen und diese
chronik patienten sind einfach maximal
aufwendig ja also eigentlich muss man
die 121 betreuen das bedeutet betreut
man einen comic patienten im schweren
verlauf kann man keinen zweiten dazu
nehmen
das heißt man ist tatsächlich die ganze
zeit eins zu eins an einem patienten
dran was muss man den ganzen machen ich
kann mir das gar nicht so richtig
vorstellen
also das ist die wunschvorstellung dass
man alles zu einzelnen patienten dran
ist es natürlich in der realität nicht
umsetzbar
aber man muss sich das so vorstellen die
patienten sind beatmet also dass die
beatmungsmaschine die muss überwacht
werden eingestellt werden kontrolliert
werden dann gibt es da ja bis 10 10 12
verschiedene medikamente die über perus
ohren laufen das sind spritzen automaten
quasi über die medikamente gegeben
werden
manche davon halten den kreislauf
aufrecht manche sorgen für die narkose
die patienten müssen ganz speziell
gelagert werden manchmal in bauchlage
gebracht werden
da muss man teil vier zeilen und das
managen zu können
wir nehmen zweistündlich oder nach
bedarf blut gaza ab das blut wird
kontrolliert auf elektrolyte auf auch
sauerstoff auch co2 wir müssen den
patienten im ganzen beobachten das ist
sehr sehr zeitaufwendig jetzt kommen wir
ja doch in die nächste phase wo es ja
schon so aussieht dass die
intensivstation wieder voll laufen
wie nimmst du die stimmung war jetzt
unter deinen ehemaligen kolleginnen die
stimmung ist schlecht und ich glaube das
ist überall so egal welches haus wie die
kollegen sind maximal demoralisiert und
dass er merkte man schon nach dem
abflachen der ersten welle und jetzt
sind wir noch mal ein stück stück weiter
also wenn ich in die gesichter meiner
kollegen problem ist dass ich schlimm
also tut mir leid ich habe hier
kommentar also wie immer seit hier und
sie sind herzlich eingeladen sich hier
zu beteiligen in den kommentaren mit
fragen mit anmerkungen mit anregungen
ich habe hier tatsächlich eine gleich
positiv schreibt den anderen stationen
geht es auch nicht besser wir bekommen
nun alle patienten egal welche
fachrichtungen essen eventuell man glück
hat gegen 11 uhr jeden tag mache ich
12.000 schritte mindestens und mehr man
versorgt und nimmt auf und pflegt und
wenn man zum klo kommt dann ist es schon
sehr dringend das trinken vergisst man
fast das ist eine ganz normale situation
mittlerweile für pflegende in
deutschland franziska ihres hab ich auch
erlebt ja dass man eine stunde lang
nicht auf die toilette dienen kann
irgendwo fest steht dass man nicht zum
trinken kommt und dann erst irgendwann
gegen nach sechs stunden dienst merkt
dass man worden nichts zu sich genommen
hat das ist eine normale härte zu zeigen
jetzt wurde ja anfang des jahres
ziemlich viel dafür getan dass so viele
betten wie möglich frei werden dass oder
bereitgestellt werden es wurden alle
möglichen menschen abgezogen und es
wurden auch bisher geltenden regeln
ausgesetzt caroline wie man hat sich das
mal angeschaut und versucht uns dass man
jetzt zu erklären
im frühjahr beschloss die
bundesregierung angesichts der pandemie
die rund 28.000 intensivbetten
verdoppeln zu wollen
das problem bis heute können einfach 20
prozent der intensivbetten nicht belegt
werden weil das personal dafür fehlt
mindestens 3500 bis 4000 intensiv
pflegekräfte um trotzdem mehr betten
belegen zu können wurde die personal
untergrenze von einer pflegekraft pro
zweieinhalb intensivpatienten ausgesetzt
heißt die intensivpflege kräfte mussten
übergangsweise deutlich mehr patienten
betreuen
so konnte die zahl der verfügbaren
intensivbetten im sommer auf über 32.000
ansteigen seit august ist die personal
untergrenze wieder in kraft und die zahl
der verfügbaren betten liegt wieder bei
rund 28.000 davon knapp die hälfte mit
beratungsmöglichkeit dazu gibt es
notfallreserven die im ernstfall
innerhalb von sieben tagen zusätzlich
aktiviert werden können
aktuell sind etwa drei viertel der
intensivbetten belegt rund zehn prozent
mit 19 patienten um im notfall wieder
mehr betten belegen zu können könnte die
personal untergrenze in der
intensivpflege wieder ausgesetzt werden
darüber spreche ich heute mit franziska
bilder ehemalige intensiv
krankenpflegerin oder krankenschwester
wie sie sich selber gerne nennt sie hat
ein buch geschrieben über ihre zeit auf
der intensivstation über diesen zustand
der pflege gleich sprechen wir noch mit
dem präsidenten der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft doktor gas aber
jetzt mal hier tatsächlich wenn wir
sehen da werden personal untergrenzen
ausgehebelt das heißt also wirklich das
wird gesagt ihr müsst euch erst noch um
mehr menschen kümmern
was heißt das im alltag ganz konkret ja
das ist natürlich aus der not geboren
also dann kann man natürlich sagen man
betreut so viele patienten wie wie eben
wie sehen sein muss und wenn es vier
sind sind es vier wohl das natürlich
nicht geht in den richtigen leben also
vier patienten intensiv patienten kann
man nicht nach bestem wissen und
gewissen betreuen und die personal
untergrenzen können wenn sie also sind
auch eingeführt worden das ist ja
eigentlich auch gut aber das führt zum
beispiel auch zu massiven personal
verschiebungen und sind auch im august
also dann wieder eingeführt wurden
das war viel zu spät also man konnte da
noch eine ganze zeit lang unter diesen
deckmäntelchen der ausgesetzten personal
untergrenzen electric weiter operieren
und ich befürchte dass wenn das ein
zweites mal passiert wird man das auch
wieder ausnutzen
warum bist du jetzt nicht auf die
intensivstation zurückgegangen ich meine
da wird jede helfende hand gesucht
sondern du bist jetzt auf einer
anästhesie station und wenn ich das
richtig verstanden und willst du da auch
bleiben
ja zurzeit ist es auch nicht so dass das
krankenhaus helfende hände gesucht also
der der aufruf der kam nie und ich habe
auch nicht mitgekriegt dass es andere
häuser tun würdest du denn auf die
intensivstation zurückgehen wenn jetzt
wieder not am mann oder an der frau ist
nein nein das mache ich kein zweites mal
ich hab ich habe das wirklich als als
als fasten menschenverachtend empfunden
wie wie es weiterging
nach dieser ersten welle mit dem
angekündigten bonus der hatten
urlaubssperre diese personen
untergrenzen waren ausgesetzt
dann wurde lavendel gepflanzt und
dosenwurst verteilt und nochmal ein
warmer händedruck und im endeffekt war
ja ganz klar dass das virus wieder kommt
man derzeit einfach nichts unternommen
um die pflegekräfte zu schützen und zu
stärken und daraus habe ich gelernt
ich guck mal hier in die kommentare es
gibt einige fragen an dich die sich
teilweise auch mit der politik
beschäftigen es gibt viele vorwürfe in
richtung gesundheitsminister jens spahn
eine frage die mich jetzt auch
interessiert zum beispiel von käfern
petermann can auf youtube kann man nicht
mehr roboter einsetzen in seiner
tätigkeit und noch mehr maschinen um
gottes willen nein also ich was soll
denn ein roboter machen es gibt ja
wirklich sachen die müssen menschen
machen und zugenommen bei stellen kann
keine maschine ersetzen
also ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen
wie in dem kontext ein roboter hilfreich
sein könnte dann gibt es hier ganz viele
kommentare auch in richtung verdienst
also einmal habe ich hier auf youtube
gesehen ich muss mal gucken ob ich den
kommentaren auch finde weil jedoch sehr
viel los ist ich scroll da mal kurz
zurück beging es genau da haben wir
können auch mal auf meinen rechner
schalten dann das ist von alex hier
augenblick
[Musik]
habe ich ihn gleich bestimmt ich hatte
ihn gerade markiert ist es wieder weg so
ist das wenn man das live macht es ging
in die richtung da ist ich habe als
gesundheits und krankenpfleger jahre
lang für 14 euro 449 die stunde
gearbeitet bei 20 patienten die
teilweise schwerst krank waren welcher
mensch würde sich so etwas antun und
dann gab es eine andere frage die sich
auch in richtung verdienst richtete
nämlich stimmt es dass intensivpfleger
innen durchschnittlich 3500 euro brutto
verdienen ist natürlich ein bisschen
wenig jedoch wäre das über dem deutschen
durchschnittsverdienst den ich ehrlich
gesagt gerade nicht kenne aber
tatsächlich die frage
franziska was verdient man denn auch so
einer intensivstation als pflegekraft
das kommt darauf an wie viele
berufsjahre hamann hat ob man die
fachweiterbildung hat und dann natürlich
irgendwelchen brief vertrag das haus
unterliegt und ich würde jetzt einfach
mal sagen zehn jahre berufserfahrung mit
fachweiterbildung das bedeutet noch mal
zwei jahre zusätzliche ausbildung also
insgesamt fünf jahre geht man mit im
öffentlichen dienst 2003 euro hin
das ist nicht wenig aber das ist auch
dafür was man da leistet in deinen augen
ausreichend oder zu wenig nein also man
muss sich einmal vor augen halten dass
wir im drei schicht system arbeiten ja
also das ist früh spät nach dienstes
beeinflusst den biorhythmus das
beeinflusst das privatleben das
sozialleben und dann arbeiten wir auch
noch zehn tage am stück am wochenende
und an feiertagen und dann möchte ich
das immer und ich finde den vergleich
kann man gut ziehen mit einem
facharbeiter in der industrie
vergleichen wie auch im schichtbetrieb
arbeiten das sind facharbeiter an
maschinen wir sind facharbeiter am
menschen aber verdienen gut mal 2000
euro weniger
jetzt haben wir gerade über diesen bonus
gesprochen und den ärger den der auch
bei dir hervorgerufen hat es war
zumindest kann man mal vielleicht so
konstatieren eine bemühungen der politik
pflege in dieser situation ein bisschen
mehr respekt zollt ist dann aber auch
wie gesagt sehr schwierig geworden julia
fiedler hat diesen konflikt und was am
ende dabei heraus gekommen ist mal für
uns zusammengefasst
systemrelevant
unverzichtbar helden der korona krise
pflegerinnen und pfleger in der pandemie
ernten sie warme worte und viel beifall
aber wie sieht er aus der finanzielle
applaus was ist dieser arbeit wert für
den öffentlichen dienst gibt es darauf
eine neue antwort durch höhere zulagen
bekommen pflegekräfte bis zu 8,7 prozent
mehr gehalt in der intensivmedizin bis
zu ziehen
außerdem die einmalige corona prämie von
maximal 600 euro
die meisten krankenhäuser sind
allerdings nicht in kommunaler hand
sondern privatwirtschaftlich organisiert
oder in kirchlicher trägerschaft
schon im mai beschloss der bundestag
eine corona prämie unabhängig vom
eigentümer abhängig von der arbeit bis
zu 1500 euro nur für beschäftigte in der
altenpflege im september wurde
nachgebessert insgesamt 100 millionen
euro sollen an krankenhäuser gehen und
zwar solche die besonders viele cupid 19
patienten behandelt haben
das heißt rund 1000 euro pro kopf für
pflege und anderes klinikpersonal
auch hier können die länder aufstocken
aber auch davon werden nicht alle
pfleger innen profitieren 433
krankenhäuser stehen auf der liste und
damit nicht mal ein drittel der kliniken
in deutschland
das ist vielleicht noch eine gute
gelegenheit jetzt mit den
krankenhausbetreibern zu lesen ich
begrüße bei uns dr gerald gaß präsident
der deutschen krankenhausgesellschaft
uns dadurch vertreten dachverband aller
krankenhäuser oder der meisten
krankenhäuser in deutschland schönen
guten abend herr gast ja schön nun haben
können sie das mal erklären dieses hin
und her mit dem pflege kraft bonus nach
dieser ersten lockdown welle wie kann
man das einem pflegenden oder einer
fliegenden erklären das ist in der tat
nicht so ganz einfach zu erklären und
ich kann auch verstehen dass viele
unverständnis haben sie haben das ja im
beitrag dargestellt ist gab zunächst
einmal einen bonus der sich nur auf die
altenpflege bezogen hat und dann gab es
viele stimmen auch von uns von den
krankenhausträgern die darauf
hingewiesen haben dass natürlich auch
und insbesondere sicherlich
krankenpflegerin
krankenpfleger aber auch andere
mitarbeiter im krankenhaus die sich in
dieser corona pandemie in der ersten
welle ganz besonders angestrengt haben
die einen unglaublichen beitrag
geleistet haben auch um die bevölkerung
zu schützen
dass die auch einen bonus verdient
hätten und darüber haben wir mit dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium aber auch
mit den gesetzlichen krankenkassen
verhandelt und es ist dann im prinzip
die formulierung und die ansage gekommen
ja wir können einen bonus ausschütten
der kann auch bezahlt werden das war die
botschaft die wir von politik und
krankenkassen bekommen haben aber der
soll sich konzentrieren auf die
krankenhäuser und die mitarbeiter die
tatsächlich corona patienten behandelt
haben und da stehen wir jetzt das sind
diese 1000 euro manche länder sind
bereit die auch weiter aufzustocken
und das geld wird bis jahresende dann
auch an die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern ausgezahlt werden bei den
krankenhäusern die entsprechend in
dieser liste der korona krankenhäuser
auch auftauchen steht dieses hin und her
und dieses auf und ab stellvertretend
für dann doch die mangelnde anerkennung
dieses berufsstandes
ich glaube nicht dass man von einer
grundsätzlich mangelnden anerkennung
sprechen kann ich weiß aber natürlich um
die wertschätzung die die pflege auch zu
recht einfordert und ich weiß dass über
die letzten jahre über viele jahre
hinweg pflege auch ein stückweit
vernachlässigt wurde auch das ist ja
deutlich geworden
wir haben in einem finanzierungssystem
arbeiten müssen wir krankenhäuser das
uns jedes jahr dazu gezwungen hat auch
personal einzusparen effizienter zu
werden
das war von allen so gewollt das will
ich ausdrücklich betonen
und jetzt sind wir seit etwa anderthalb
jahren in einen neuen system das ist
politisch entschieden worden wir haben
das sehr begrüßt nach der letzten
bundestagswahl
die pflege wird separat finanziert und
es gibt für die krankenhausträger keinen
anlass mehr an pflege zu sparen im
gegenteil wir versuchen händeringend
pflegekräfte zu gewinnen seit anderthalb
jahren
wir haben auch vorher schon nachgelegt
aber jetzt mit dieser neuen finanzierung
haben wir jetzt auch die wirtschaftliche
möglichkeiten dazu und die versuchen wir
auch umzusetzen aber
köhler hat ja darauf hingewiesen
pflegekräfte wachsen leider nicht auf
den bäumen und im moment ist es vielfach
ein abwerben von anderen und das hilft
dem system natürlich nur bedingt wir
müssen in pflege investieren in junge
menschen und das nehmen wir schon war
auch infolge der ersten welle und
infolge der wertschätzung die die pflege
bekommen hat und ich rede hier nicht nur
über den applaus merken wir dass sich
vermehrt junge menschen um ausbildung
bewerben in unseren krankenpflegeschulen
ich finde das ist ein ermutigendes
signal
es wird aber einige jahre dauern um
tatsächlich mehr pflege ans krankenbett
zu bringen das dauert leider einige zeit
herr doktor gast das war jetzt sehr
viele auf einmal das muss man glaube ich
noch mal in kleine stückchen gleich
unterteilen weil nicht jeder in diesem
doch sehr komplexen systemen so drin ist
ich möchte mich an die zuschauer im
stream wenden die in den kommentaren
unterwegs sind einerseits gibt es hier
mal wieder eine diskussion ob das jetzt
überhaupt wirklich so eine schlimme
pandemie ist die möchte ich heute
wirklich ausklammern weil wir haben hier
viele streams dazu gemacht wir haben mit
vielen experten darüber geredet und sind
immer zu dem schluss gekommen dass wir
es hier mit einer nicht zu
unterschätzenden situation zu tun haben
und ich möchte wirklich ist auch um
bitten dass wir das machen den
kommentaren versuchen mal sein zu lassen
es gibt jetzt fragen oder beschwerden
wir würden keine kritischen fragen zu
lassen das ist auch nicht richtig ich
versuche sie alle hier aufzunehmen aber
ich bitte da einfach um verständnis wir
haben gerade wirklich ein hohes
kommentar aufkommen und es ist schwierig
da hinterher zu kommen
und jetzt müssen wir glaube ich ganz
kurz mal erklären was herr doktor gast
gerade schon gesagt hat also wenn jemand
ins krankenhaus kommt dann wird
abgerechnet nach sogenannten
fallpauschalen früher war die
ausschlaggebende kriterium an den
liegezeit also wie lange jemand im
krankenhaus jetzt seit ungefähr 13
jahren geht es darum was für eine
krankheit hatte er und was ist das
ungefähr an kosten für das krankenhaus
und dann kriegen die krankenhäuser das
entsprechend ersetzt aber die pflege ist
lange zeit da nicht wirklich
berücksichtigt worden wir haben mal
jemanden gefragt der sich damit sehr gut
auskennt professor michael simon der ist
irritiert hat professor für
gesundheitspolitik an der uni hannover
wie lange das mit dem flieger stand
eigentlich schon so ist und da hast hat
bei uns geantwortet die schwierige
situation im pflegedienst der
krankenhäuser hält bereits sehr lange an
bestimmt 30 jahre
ende der 80er jahre gab es bereits in
diskussionen pflegenotstand in
krankenhäusern
das besserte sich in den 90er jahren ja
aber seit mitte der 1990 er jahre haben
ihren stellen abbauen er wurde durch die
einführung der fallpauschalen noch
erheblich verschärft so damit habe ich
eine frage auch beantwortet die auf
youtube aufgaben nämlich ob der
personalmangel nicht erst seit der
privatisierung der krankenhäuser da ist
nein ist er nicht aber er will dadurch
verschärft sie haben gerade gesagt herr
doktor gas als präsident der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft dass sie quasi
dazu gezwungen sind das klingt ein
bisschen nach opfer konnten sie da
überhaupt nichts tun die letzten 13
jahre
naja das soll nicht nach opfer klingen
sondern es stellt einfach das system da
wir haben einen fallpauschalen system
ist es ja eben beschrieben worden was
jedes jahr in einer preisentwicklung
fortgeschrieben wurde und schon diese
preisentwicklung ist regelhaft hinter
der tarifsteigerung zurückgeblieben das
heißt wir waren vom system her immer
wieder dazu angehalten personal sparen
da die prozesse zu kreieren zu
entwickeln und damit eben auch
wirtschaftlicher zu arbeiten das ist das
seil nicht mal zur politik gegangen und
haben die kurven gezeigt haben gesagt es
fehlt uns soundsoviel tausende personal
da muss man doch was tun das haben wir
gemacht nicht nur einmal sondern jedes
jahr und das mehrfach und das weitere
ist wir müssen aus dem geld was wir von
den krankenkassen über diese
fallpauschalen bekommen auch noch im
prinzip systemwidrig einen teil unserer
investitionen finanzieren für die
eigentlich die bundesländer zuständig
sind auch ein missstand drei milliarden
euro im jahr fehlen den krankenhäusern
und das hat zuletzt sogar die
bundesregierung festgestellt im
krankenhaus zukunfts gesetz wird
formuliert dass dieses gesetz jetzt in
die bresche springt für die fehlenden
finanzmittel der länder auch das mussten
die krankenkassen die krankenhäuser aus
diesen fallpauschalen refinanzieren
insofern will ich damit nur deutlich
machen wir standen und stehen unter
einem enormen wirtschaftlichen druck es
ist politisch gewollt dass krankenhäuser
so wirtschaftlich wie möglich arbeiten
aber da muss man ein bisschen
differenzieren es gibt ja einmal die
landeskrankenhäuser und dann gibt
dass auch viele kliniken die in privater
ein privatwirtschaftlicher hand sind die
ja durchaus darauf ausgelegt sind dass
sie profit bringen und die ja auch
durchaus teilweise profit abwerfen und
das wird dann ja auch wieder auf den
rücken des personals gemacht das heißt
da wird geguckt wie viel braucht man
tatsächlich und wo kann man noch ans
limit gehen das ist doch ein system was
eigentlich darauf ausgelegt ist
irgendwann zusammenzubrechen
zunächst mal muss man sagen ganz
grundsätzlich jenseits der träger gruppe
ob das kirchliche träger sind
öffentliche träger oder private träger
wir sind alle angehalten und es ist
schlicht und ergreifend notwendig dass
wir positive betriebsergebnisse erzielen
um überhaupt investieren zu können ich
habe das eben versucht darzustellen
wir haben aber tatsächlich die situation
dass ein drittel der krankenhäuser seit
vielen jahren verluste schreibt ein
drittel kommt gerade mit einer schwarzen
null raus und ein weiteres drittel
schreibt noch positive
betriebsergebnisse aber das große
beträge da aus dem system heraus
transportiert werden das ist sicherlich
kein flächendeckendes thema ich habe
hier viele kritische stimmen gerade zu
diesem themenkomplex herr gas
gewinnorientierte krankenhäuser also
hier wird gesagt krankenhäuser dürfen
halt keine gewinnorientierten
einrichtungen seien da fängt es mal an
von markus auf facebook es gibt ein
kommentar auf youtube wäre es nicht viel
sozialer krankenhäuser zurück unter
staatlichen leitung zu geben so lange
immer weiter privatisiert wird gilt geld
leider immer als wertschätzung
das heißt also das ist doch ein system
dass er dazu führt dass die pflege ans
limit kommt wie wir jetzt feststellen
dass wir in einer pandemie einfach gar
nicht mehr genau wissen wo wir die leute
herkriegen sollen die tatsächlich die
menschen versorgen
er ist dass der geburtsfehler vor 13
jahren gewesen der uns jetzt um die
ohren fliegt ich selbst bin ja
geschäftsführer eines
krankenhausverbundes der unter
öffentlicher trägerschaft steht aber es
ist keinesfalls so dass man jetzt sagen
kann die privaten sind diejenigen die
das system ausnutzen die das system
quasi so justiert haben dass sie davon
die profite profite erwirtschaften
können sondern wir leiden alle unter
diesem system und deswegen gibt es jetzt
auch die umstellung ich habe da in dem
ersten statement darauf hingewiesen
haben
eine neue finanzierung und das ist
glaube ich die botschaft wir können die
trägervielfalt durchaus erhalten wir
müssen kein statisches krankenhauswesen
einführen wir müssen nur die
rahmenbedingungen die für die
krankenhäuser gelten entsprechend
umwandeln wir müssen eben und das ist
die forderung der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft eine pflege
personalbemessung in kraft setzen das
fordern wir gemeinsam mit der
gewerkschaft verdi und dem deutschen
pflegerat das heißt also auch wir
krankenhausträger gehen in die offensive
und erwarten von der politik hier
entscheidungen die die rahmenbedingungen
im hinblick auf die personalausstattung
deutlich verbessern und da sind die
privaten genauso mit im boot wie die
freigemeinnützigen kirchlichen oder
öffentlichen träger aber jetzt mal ganz
kurz zusammengefasst wären sie dafür
dass man das rückabwickeln und sagt es
sollte keine gewinnorientierten privaten
krankenhäusern ergeben wir müssen uns
dass das deutsche gesellschaft leisten
dass sowas auch dann mal geld kostet die
privaten krankenhausträger sind nicht
vor 13 jahren entstanden sondern das ist
ein prozess eine entscheidung für vor
vielen vielen jahrzehnten gefallen wurde
getroffen wurde wenn man das jetzt
ändern möchte muss man sich darüber im
klaren sein dass das ein komplettes
system wandel bedeutet man muss dann
auch bereit seien letztlich diese
privaten träger zu entschädigen das ist
nicht mit einem federstrich getan und
ich glaube es ist auch nicht notwendig
weil das nicht das grundübel unseres
krankenhauswesens unseres systems ist
sondern das grundübel sind die
rahmenbedingungen unter denen die
krankenhäuser wirtschaften müssen
die wurde jetzt zumindest für die
pflegenden geändert haben sie auch
gerade schon angesprochen
das heißt der pflegeaufwand ist aus
diesem fallpauschalensystem rausgenommen
worden und die krankenhäuser können
jetzt mit den krankenkassen sagen oder
abrechnen hier ich habe den
pflegeaufwand
dafür möchte ich bitte dieses geld das
ist eine entwicklung die hat lang
gedauert die ist vielleicht auch nicht
ganz schlecht wir haben auch da nochmal
professor simon gefragt den emeritierten
professor der gesund für
gesundheitspolitik der uni hannover was
er davon hält die herausnahme der pflege
personalkosten aus dem körper schauen
halte ich für sehr wichtig
jetzt sieht die gesetzliche regelung vor
dass sie tatsächlich personalkosten
erstattet werden das problem ist
mittlerweile aber nach so vielen jahren
der unterbesetzung dass es schwierig ist
pflegepersonal überhaupt zu gewinnen
viele kamen viele pflegekräfte sind aus
dem ausland weg gegangen ist und mehrere
zehntausend pflegekräfte in den letzten
20 jahren aussehen kann aus einer
ausgewachsenen die ambulante pflege
pflegeheime andere bereiche und die sind
offensichtlich bereit in der in die
kanalisation zu kehren und insofern
haben wir jetzt eine gute finanzierung
irgendwie finde aber wir haben nicht
genug pflegepersonal das breites unter
diesen arbeitsbedingungen wieder in die
krankenhäuser zurückzukehren
wenn ich dann mal ganz platt fragen darf
herr dr gass als vertreter der
krankenhausgesellschaft was machen wir
denn jetzt
na ja wir machen jetzt genau das was
notwendig ist in einer solchen situation
ich habe schon darauf hingewiesen das
lässt sich nicht mit dem umlegen eines
schalters korrigieren sondern wir
investieren jetzt in ausbildung wir
versuchen über meer krankenpflegeschulen
über mehr ausbildung zum einen junge
menschen dazu zu bewegen in diesen beruf
einzutreten auch das ist nicht einfach
angesichts der demografischen
entwicklung gibt es einen wettbewerb um
die jungen leute aber ich denke wir
haben hier gute chancen pflege ist bei
allen schwierigkeiten auch das hat frau
köhler gesagt auch ein toller beruf wenn
die rahmenbedingungen stimmen und das
geht jetzt nur schrittweise wir
versuchen menschen wieder
zurückzugewinnen
und mit jeder zusätzlichen helfenden
hand in der station auf der station in
den abteilungen verbessert sich die
situation insgesamt und dadurch kommen
wir wieder in einer situation wo die
spirale nach oben geht und eben nicht
nach unten aber wie lange dauert das bis
wir wirklich aus der situation
herauskommen können dass das dauert
sicherlich 58 jahre bis das wirklich in
vollem umfang wirksam werden kann aber
ich frag mal zurück was ist die
alternative jetzt nichts zu tun kann ja
nicht die alternative sein wir haben
jetzt begonnen die finanzierung stimmt
wir versuchen jetzt alles um die
arbeitsbedingungen schon unter den
gegebenen sie in der gegebenen situation
zu verbessern
wir versuchen natürlich auch
pflegekräfte aus dem ausland zu gewinnen
wir versuchen pflegekräfte zu gewinnen
die von teils
auf vollzeit umsteigen die vielleicht
aus dem beruf ausgeschieden sind wieder
zurück zu kommen und ich die haben eben
im beitrag gesehen wie wir auch bei den
einkommen verbessert haben das war jetzt
ein tarifvertrag intensivpflege plus
zehn prozent normal pflege + 9% und
diese tarifverträge die lösen einen
wettbewerb aus dem können sich andere
tarifverträge in diesem
finanzierungssystem nicht mehr entziehen
und ich prognostiziere ihnen die anderen
tarifverträge werden nachziehen und dann
wird sich auch diese situation
verbessern und das sind alles einzelne
schritte in diesem dauerlauf den wir vor
uns haben
wir haben kleine ali an etwa einen
dauerlauf vor allem auf den
intensivstationen mit dem cockpit 19
patienten
was sagen sie denn jetzt den fliegenden
die tatsächlich jetzt gerade an den bart
maschinen stehen oder wissen in den
nächsten tagen und wochen wird meine
station sehr sehr voll seien zuallererst
mal bedanke ich möchte mich bei diesen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
die haben wirklich enormes zu leisten
die hatten schon enorm es zu leisten im
frühjahr und das was jetzt gerade wieder
auf uns zukommt wird sich noch
verstärken wird in den kommenden wochen
ist ein ausnahmezustand für uns alle und
also auch das wohn und durch nein nicht
augen zu und durch was wir jetzt tun wir
führen das regel versorgungssystem
zurück um personal frei zu bekommen um
dann diese corona station sowohl im
normal pflegebereich wie auch auf der
intensivstation zu verstärken
vorbilder hat sie auch angesprochen
diese infektions patienten haben einen
deutlich höheren pflegeaufwand und den
können wir nur realisieren indem wir
personal zusammen ziehen andere
behandlungen zurückführen
das führt zu wartezeiten bei den
patienten da sind wir in einem dilemma
auch als krankenhäuser als mediziner als
pflegekräfte sind wir in einem dilemma
zu entscheiden wer muss jetzt warten
weil wir eben das personal konzentrieren
müssen
und das sind jetzt die aufgaben die jede
klinik vor ort leistet in der
zusammenarbeit mit den mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeitern ich hoffe sehr dass wir in
einigen monaten über den berg sind gibt
es einen kommentar der möchte ich ihnen
noch zum abschluss einmal vorlesen ist
eine zumutung schreibt arno moos auf
facebook sparen also der
gesundheitsminister weiß seit spätestens
märz bescheid und es passiert
nicht genug der mann ist völlig
überfordert unterschreiben sie das ja
ich muss zurückfahren was hat man für
eine erwartung gehabt also niemand
konnte jetzt ernsthaft erwarten dass es
uns möglich ist von märz bis heute die
anzahl der pflegekräfte auf den
intensivstationen signifikant zu erhöhen
was aber passiert ist wir haben mehrere
tausend pflegekräfte von den
normalstation im rahmen von kurz
qualifikationen geschult damit sie
unterstützen können damit sie die
qualifizierten teams die erfahrenen
teams auf den intensivstationen
unterstützen bei der beatmung
unterstützen können das ist das was wir
tun konnten in dieser kurzen zeit
ich darf noch mal dran erinnern die
pandemie kam für uns im frühjahr im
januar alle höchst überraschend niemand
konnte sich das vorstellen und vor
dieser situation stehen wir
herr dr gass als vertreter der
krankenhäuser der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft vielen dank
heute abend und ich gehe mit diesem
vorschlag oder wird genau diesem
statement dass man jetzt pflegekräfte um
schuld für diesen bereich gehe ich
zurück zu franziska bilder die die ganze
zeit zugehört hat ehemalige intensiv
krankenschwester franziska ist das die
lösung
dass man jetzt menschen oder
pflegekräfte die in einem ganz anderen
bereich gab es wird haben bis jetzt mal
schnell um schuld auf intensivstation
nein das ist nicht die lösung zum einen
fehlen diese kollegen eben auch der
station von der sie abgezogen werden und
zum zweiten braucht man für die
intensivpflege erfahrung und da rede ich
nicht von sechs monaten und ich rede
auch nicht von einem jahr und musste
schwer kranke patienten die beatmet
werden versorgen zu können da der raum
an berufserfahrung und da braucht man da
hilft kein crash kurs also man kann
jetzt auch keinen internisten umschulen
und und ihm das operieren beibringen und
sagen so ist brauchst du die prothesen
das würde man auch nicht wollen und das
erwartet man auch nicht von seiner
pflegekraft die qualifiziert sein sollen
so jetzt haben wir viel darüber geredet
wo es überall mangelt in der pflege das
wird uns medien auch manchmal
vorgeworfen dass wir diesen beruf so
schlecht reden
franziska warum tut man sich sind dann
noch an wenn der so furchtbar ist ich
würde da eigentlich von antun
reden ich glaube das wort ist gar nicht
angebracht ich liebe meinen beruf und
ich mache gerne und ich bin persönlich
und kognitiv gefordert ich muss leistung
bringen und ich sehe wenn das früchte
trägt und das macht spaß am ende des
tages einfach seinen teil dazu
beigetragen zu haben dass jemand gesund
wird ja dass man jemandem das leben
gerettet hat das bringt kein anderer
beruf mit sich und deswegen mache ich
das einfach gerne wenn die bedingungen
stimmen so ich habe jetzt ganz ganz
viele kommentare hier die ich sehr gerne
vorlesen würde dann werden wir aber noch
ungefähr eine stunde beschäftigt und ich
glaube so viel zeit hat heute abend
niemand mehr
ich möchte einmal stellvertretend den
kommentar von layla vorlesen auf
facebook ich bin eine kreative aber
nichts was ihr vorschlag macht den beruf
weder für mich noch für ausgetretene
pfleger interessant jeder der erzählt er
ist in der pflege oder ziehe da bin ich
nur also den bewohner ich und muss den
hut ziehen diese menschen verdienen so
viel mehr als nur unseren applaus und
ich kann aber auch noch was finde ich
ganz positives mit geben so zum
abschluss vielleicht auch für dich fremd
sie dem iran treibt auf youtube ich habe
meine ausbildung zur pflegefachkraft
dieses jahr begonnen und muss sagen ich
bereue ist 0
klar war der start mit der ersten ko
runde wenn er nicht der beste aber was
soll's als schlusswort fragen sie was
willst du denn wünschen was braucht es
aus seiner perspektive damit dieser
beruf wirklich auch so spaß macht wie du
es dir immer vorgestellt hat also wir
brauchen kollegen wir brauchen kollegen
die nachkommen und den müssen aber auch
alles dafür tun dass die kollegen die
noch im beruf sind auch bleiben also
erfahrenes personal muss die flüssiges
gold behandelt werden wir brauchen
rahmenbedingungen die passen
wir haben eine anspruchsvolle ausbildung
durchlaufen und wir wissen wie wir
patienten individuell versorgen müssen
und können nach bestem wissen und
gewissen und dass diese
rahmenbedingungen brauchen wir wieder
dass einfach jeder patient jeder mensch
die pflege bekommt die er verdient und
benötigt jetzt habe ich kann mir gerade
bei gaz gehört vertreter der
krankenhäuser der sagte also wir bemühen
uns wir versuchen wir tun wir haben
sehen das problem
nimmst du das den krankenhäusern ab
ja also mit vielen mit mit vielen
maßnahmen halte man das symptom aber
nicht die krankheit und natürlich kann
man sich die pflegekräfte nicht nicht
backen das stimmt schon also das geht
nicht aber man muss einfach die kollegen
die jetzt noch arbeiten und dessen
fünften motivation haben die muss man
irgendwie halten und das geht eben nicht
mit lavendel und dosenwurst das war ein
schönes schlusswort vielen dank
franziska bilder dass du heute abend
zeit für uns hat das vielen dank für
eure ganzen fragen und kommentare
wie gesagt ich würde noch sehr sehr
gerne mehr davon vorlesen aber es war
wir sind wirklich überwältigt über euer
kommentar aufkommen von daher sage ich
jetzt erstmal vielen dank fürs dabeisein
fürs schreiben fürs fragen fürs
kommentieren und ich hoffe dann bis zum
nächsten mal macht's gut
schon schießen